Okay, welcome everyone to the DDPS seminar.
Before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and logistics. First
of all, please mute yourself during the talk,
but if you have questions, you can
unmute and ask questions during the talk,
or you can leave your questions in the
chat room so that we can address them
in Q A session at the end second, today's
DDPS seminar is open to external audience,
therefore no classified this question is allowed.
So please watch out. Finally, the talk today will
be recorded and uploaded in our YouTube channel.
Alright, let me introduce our speaker today. It
is an honor to host Doctor Akil nakki, who
is a postdoctoral scholar in the Division
of Engineering and Applied Sciences at Caltech. He
received his PhD from the University of California
San Diego in 2023 His research interests include
reduced order modeling, hydrodynamic stability,
aero acoustics and turbulent flows. He specializes
in high fidelity numerical simulations and
developing data driven techniques for flow
control and the discovery of low physics. Today,
Akhil will talk about data driven techniques for
analysis of turbulent flows. I'm sure we are going
to hear a wonderful talk from him before I
pass the button to Akil as a tradition to
the DDPS seminar, let me ask a somewhat informal
questions to him, just to get to know him better.
And today's questions to you, Akil is I happens
to know that you like to listen to the audiobook,
and you likes the non fictions. And if you
recommend any non one, I mean, if you recommend
one non fiction book to everyone, and and why, if
you can share that with us, that would be awesome.
Yeah. So the recently, I've been listening to
this audio book called chaos, the making of a new
science by James leek, yeah, I kind of like it,
it's, it's, it's like difference. It's different
stories of different scientists from various
fields and how they encountered chaos and so on.
So I find it, like, really interesting and, yeah,
inspiring. So I probably recommend that. Is it,
is it easy to read? Yeah,
it's easy to read. Oh, cool. Okay. It's more like
stories. You don't have any
technical stuff, yeah? Okay,
I might, I might listen to that as well. Thank
you for recommendation. Okay, the flow is yours.
Yeah? Thanks for the introduction. So today I'm
going to talk about the recent advancements that
we have made in data driven techniques
for analysis of turbulent flows. Okay?
Yeah. So turbulent flows are chaotic
in nature, and as a result of which,
they're very hard to predict. Additionally, they
exhibit a wide range of scales, going from large
scales to small scales. And it is these. To get a
complete picture of these turbulent flows, we have
to refine all these, even these very small scales,
which requires a fine mesh, and this is this makes
them computationally challenging to simulate.
However, even within this highly chaotic nature,
there exists some orderly patterns of motion,
which we term them as coherent structures. And
in these coherent structures are dynamically and
also energetically important in these turbulent
flows. As an example, here are the experiments
of a mixing layer by Brown and Roscoe. As we can
see here. These are this at the top panel is the
lower Reynolds number. At the bottom panel is a
higher Reynolds number, where we can see that
even on increasing the higher Reynolds number,
the large scale structure more or less doesn't
change, but the num the small scale structure
significantly changes. So this, this gives us
an understanding of of why it is important to
understand these large scale structures so that
it can be easy to understand and model turbulent
flows. And here are two additional examples of the
wake of a flat plate where and a gulf stream where
we see that. Here as well, we see the presence of
a large scale structure that is representative of
a Von Karman Water Street. And these coherent
structures are are actually present in all kind
of turbulent flows, and even in oceanographic
flows. As an example of here is the presence
of these large meso scales which are responsible
for the circulatory motion of these ocean so one,
the one application which I'm more interested
about is which I focused in my research is the
generation of jet noise. So here is. An
example of a military jet during takeoff,
and as the flow comes out from the nozzle
exit, it interacts with the surrounding,
ambient fluid and forms these coherent
structures, which are the sources of
jet noise. And this is a numerical rendition of
this, where here we can see that these coherent
structure emit radiations in the downstream
direction and in the sideline direction,
and especially the downstream propagating waves
have are significantly loud and and can result,
and can result about to hearing loss for the
people working in the near field, and also to
the people living nearby the airports during
takeoff and landing and so and here is a neat
example by from the taken from the work of Nichols
and Lele where we can see the coherent structure
being emitted from these radiation being emitted
from this coherent structure. So the goal here is
to first characterize these coherent structures,
and then develop techniques so that we can control
the emission of noise. So this is where these
data driven techniques come into picture. So,
so given a turbulent flow field, they help us
in extracting these coherent structures. And by
extracting these coherent structures we can they
provide us a low dimensional representation of
the system. And once we have a low dimensional
representational system, we can then develop
reduced order modeling of these flows, and
then further perform flow control. And here
is an example of the flow control performed by
Mora et al, where they have used eigen system
realization algorithm to perform, to delay the
bypass transition in boundary layers. So first, by
using these kind of techniques, one can not only
reduce the computational complexity, but can also
manipulate them for various different uses. So
what kind of data driven techniques to use? There
exists a wide range of data driven techniques
existing from proper orthogonal decomposition,
dynamic mode decomposition and various other
techniques as well. So the in this talk, I will
focus on spectral proper orthogonal decomposition,
and recently it has emerged as a popular tool for
analyzing turbulent flows. So it the original
work, and traces back to the work of Lumley in
late 1960s and early 70s, where he laid out the
mathematical framework for it a essentially in one
sentence. It is the frequency domain version
of the principal component analysis, and its
major advantage is that it extracts modes that
are coherent in both space as well as in time.
So what we do in in spod is we first compute the
cross spectral density matrix and then solve this
Eigenvalue problem to obtain the modes and the I
and the eigenvalue the reason why it has become a
powerful tool for analyzing turbulent flows is
because of its equivalence with other methods,
as shown recently by taune et al, where they
show that spod has the counterpart with respect
to the resolvent analysis, which is an operator
driven method, and they have shown that the spod
modes are nothing but the spatially uncorrelated
white noise forcing resolvent response modes. And
similarly, they have also shown that spod modes
are optimally average DMD modes. So overall,
considering the advantage of this and its
equivalence with other methods we will use,
I will, we will use this for various different
extensions. So this brings me to the outline of
my talk. So I have divided into three different
parts. And in the first part of this talk I will,
I will show how we extend this for estimating
missing data in a flow field, and in the second
in the second part, I will go over how we use this
for identifying the intermittency of coherence
structures. Excuse me. And in the third part, we
will extend this to to higher order statistics,
to the third order statistics to identify the
triadic interactions. So first, why it is,
why it is important to estimate the missing data.
So many experimental measurements contain gaps or
artifacts, for example, in particle image. Here is
an example of particle image emerging velocimetry
of gas Tur turbine combustion, where you can see
the presence of these gaps. These gaps can occur
due to various reasons, probably they they are
due to reflection from the surface or the lack
of seeding particles. And similarly, even in
satellite measurements as well, the presence
of the cloud cover can block these measurements,
and as a result, we might get these gaps in the
sea surface temperatures. So it is, as in, so
it is essential to get a complete flow picture,
to to to first analyze these flows, and in order
to get, in order to get a complete data set.
Uh. Researchers have used different techniques,
which includes interpolation, Kriging and gappy
pod. So Kriging can be both spatial and Interpol,
spatial and temporal interpolation. And so the so
the recent the gap epod was originally proposed
by Everson and serovic and later extended by
venturi karnatakas. And further, they have
been significantly more extensions of this
for different applications as well. So as opposed
to this, what we do in this work is, is we propose
a method that leverages both the spatial and
temporal coherence for reconstructing this missing
data and on doing so this we have that this method
can has also has different various different
applications. For example, they can be used in
non linear model reduction and also, for example,
in the optimal place placements of sensory and
here is in here is the example of young et al,
where they have optimal weather selected optimal
placements of sensors for ocean measurements. And
in this, in this work, they have used gappy
pod. So we to demonstrate our method we use,
we use the experimental data set that was
acquired by Zhang katasta nuclei, where they have,
where they have, where they have performed
experiments of a turbulent cavity flow at a
high Reynolds number of three to point 3.3. Into
10 to power minus 10, Power Five and a Mach number
of point six. And this data sets contains total
about 16,000 snapshots. So before I go into the
algorithm of the method. So this is just a quick
sneak peek showing that even in the case where
we remove 20% of missing data and where these
data have been, these missing regions have been
randomly seeded and sized, we observe that our
algorithm is able to perform well and reconstruct
the missing region, and it's comparable to that
of the original data. So to first start off,
I will first give an overview of spod, and then,
and then our gap, gap epspod. So so spod first
starts off by taking all the snapshot ensembles,
and then once we have the snapshot on ensembles,
we then divide them into overlapping blocks,
and where each o each block is considered
as a statistically independent realization
according to the ergodic hypothesis. And then
we perform Fourier transform on each block. So
once we do this, we obtain different frequencies
in each blocks, as seen by the different colors
here, then we choose the same frequency from each
block and arrange them into a new matrix. This
is the matrix of Fourier realizations. So once
we have this matrix of four realization we can
then compute the cross spectral density matrix,
which is given by this, and then solve this
Eigenvalue problem to obtain the spod modes
and eigenvalues that is lambda. So to give a quick
example of performing spod on the turbulent cavity
flow this. So this is the cavity flow. And if we
perform spod on this, we get two main outputs. One
is the eigenvalue spectrum, and two is the modes.
So the eigenvalue spectrum shows us that how the
energy is distributed across different frequencies
and at one frequency, how it is distributed across
different eigenvectors. So the first this
spectrum is the first is the first spod mode,
or the leading spod mode, and contains the most
energy and is sorted in the decreasing order of
its energy preference. And here I'm showing four
different modes of a low frequency to higher
frequencies, and two of which corresponds to the
different Rossier frequencies. So using this,
we can first identify the spod modes, which
represents the different coherence structures.
And now we will use these coherence structures
to reconstruct back the original flow field.
So to reconstruct back the original flow field.
It requires an inverse spod process. So in this,
what is required is, first you we can think
of this as the data being decomposed as a
linear combination of these different
spod modes. And so for this, for this,
we have to first obtain the expansion coefficient
for each of these, each of these modes, which can
be directly obtained from the spod by a rescaling
of these of the of the Kronos, or psi given here.
Once we have the expansion coefficients, we can
then obtain back the Fourier realization by a
multiplication of. The modes with with that of
the expansion coefficient, and take the inverse,
Fourier transform to obtain back the blocks, and
finally, get back the data. Notice that we might
have to consider into effect the of the of overlap
between blocks, so we can do a weighted average
to get get this back. So now, since we are able
to reconstruct the data from that of the modes
I will show how we have used extended this for
for reconstructing of missing data. So consider,
so consider a case where there is some missing
data or has compromised region. So in this case,
if we would form spod on the entire data set, that
was that will that would result in modes which are
that would result in modes which are corrupted or
have these missing regions. So what we do is we to
circumvent this. We first divide them into each
blocks, and then remove the blocks that remove
the blocks that contain these missing regions
while performing spod, and then perform spod on
the remaining blocks. So once we do this, we have
all the expansion coefficients for the remaining
blocks, but not for the the block that has this
missing region. So to obtain this, what we do is
we now we project these, these blocks, onto the
good modes, that is, the modes that have been
computed excluding these compromised regions. By
doing this, we can get the expansion coefficients
of these missing block for example. And once
we get the expansion coefficient again, we form
a same as a same same process as previously,
where we get compute the Fourier realization,
and then take the inverse Fourier transform to get
back the blocks, and then use this to fill in the
fill in the snapshot. Note that so this is we do
this for one gap, and then we do this iteratively
so that all the missing region in one particular
gap has been converged. And by converge, I mean
the the the solution that has been by predicted
by our algorithm does not change even for even as
the iteration number changes. So once it reaches
that point, we assume it has reached convergence.
So this is and we do this for one gap at a time,
and then once we from, once we finish one gap, we
move on to the next gap, and do this iteratively
for all gaps. And this is what we term as the
outer loop that is filling all the gaps once is
considered as outer loop. And then we again repeat
this process entirely over all gaps multiple times
such that the entire solution does not change. And
so this is what we term as the global loop for
this algorithm. So now to look at some results.
So here, here, here is the result of of the case
of a 5% of missing data shown, shown by here,
where these gaps also have been chosen random,
chosen randomly. So what I'm plotting here is
on the y axis, the global relative error. On the x
axis is the iteration number. And as you can see,
the global relate to error starts from one,
and as each of the gaps starts getting filled,
it decreases and finally converges to a certain
value of here, it's about point two. Note that
here in this the distance or the iteration numbers
between these two gray dash lines represents the
inner loop, that is each gap being filled up
till convergence. So this is also shown here,
where this relative error represents the relative
error for each individual gap. And as for
convergence. Here we have used a tolerance of 10
to the power minus eight as a l2 norm. And if once
the l2 norm reaches 10 power minus eight, then
we assume that has converged for this particular
gap. And so this here, I'm showing three different
gaps. And so this is the inner loop here, and the
outer loop represents the filling of all the gaps
once that is filling of this, this, this, this,
and so on up till end and that is given by this
extent, and up to the blue, up to the blue solid
line over here. And finally, global loop is the
total number of iteration it takes for the final
value to converge. So yeah. So here is an example
of the 5% case. Now we also considered three
different cases of 1% 5% and 20% and we observe
that in all cases, our our algorithm is able to
is able to reconstruct the data and. Also reaches
about 20% in a relative error of 20% in each case,
note that the only difference, for the significant
difference here is, as you have higher number of
data, you require a higher number of missing
data. You require a more number of iterations
to finally converge to the minimum value.
And so now, till I've shown the quantitative
estimates. Now here, for a qualitative
representation, here I'm showing three
different snapshots, and where the first snapshot
represents the individual error which has maximum
instantaneous error. As you can see here,
a large part of the flow field over here
is missing and but are even even in such a case,
our method, as it leverages both the spatial and
temporal coherence, it is able to reconstruct
the flow field and is and is comparable to that
of the of that of that of the original data over
here. And this is also observed for two two other
time instances which have been randomly chosen.
And here as well, we observe that our algorithm
is able to estimate the data in these regions. Now
we compare our method to two standard methods such
as Kriging and gappy pod. So here we I consider
all three different cases and also another,
another data set of a cylinder flow at a low
Reynolds number. So overall, in all these cases,
what we observe is our method, the gappy spod,
outperforms with Kriging and gappy pod. So here,
the relative error is shown on the y axis and the
mode so the mode number is shown on the x axis.
So note that this mode number arises due to the
gappy pod, where they have a free parameter. So
the what in gappy pod, what is done is they, they
perform the analysis for different mode numbers,
and finally, choose the mode which, which gives
them the least, least error, not mode number,
but the number of modes. So overall here,
what we observe is, in all cases, gappy pod is
significant, shows a significant lower error than
both of that of gappy pod and that of clicking,
I have a question. So as pod, gapy spod
does not depends on the number of modes. No.
So what we do is we use the entire number
of modes. We use all the modes. Yes,
so it does not depend. I mean, it can technically
also depend by using a certain number of modes,
but we find, yeah, you can also do that if, if
there are some computational limitations to that,
but it does not depend on that. And in what we
observe is, if we use all the modes, is that that
is when we get the least number of results, least
error. So that's why it does not depend on board
number, yeah, well, the computational cost
of the spod would be higher than KP pod, then
um, not technique. So technically, so was you
using all I mean in terms of memory, yes. In terms
of memory, yes, but in terms of computational
time, probably not, because here for gap epod,
the you have to converge it for each mode, and
then move on to the next mode and then converge it
for that, and so on, so on. And then you have to
repeat this process for Repeat this entire process
for filling in all the data for multiple for all
different modes, number, right? Like if, let's say
the data set has 10,000 snapshots, then you have
10,000 different modes. So it requires doing all
that. So computational in terms of time, it would
probably be gappy pod is higher in some cases,
in some cases it's not. It's overall similar.
I mean, yeah, we have shown this in our paper,
but we find that overall it's comparable in terms
of memory. Yes, the spod is probably higher.
Okay, looks like Palani has no questions.
Yes, hi, thanks. Hi again. This is parni here
from India. I have a question on the previous
slide where you showed the global relative error
coming down to 20% for all three different sets
missing data of 1% or five or 20% is there
any significance to why the global relative
error comes down to 20% for all the cases,
irrespective of the amount of missing data?
I actually think it's like, I actually think it's
a coincidence, and it's, there is no guaranteed
measure. It's just a coincidence. Yeah, there is
no significance, as you can so that is only what
we observed in the presence of this cavity, for
this cavity flow, whereas if you look actually
at the cylinder flow, the error is you can
see that as the for different. Percentages
of missing data. The error is different, so I
think it's just a coincidence. Yeah, thanks.
I may ask 100% all these resources for the
predictive case or the reproductive case,
I mean you, you observe the data, and you
try to predict the observed data again,
or is it like try to predict the new
Okay, so here, what we do is, actually we have
the original data from the experiments, and
what we do is we select regions which we remove
those regions, right? And then we using this,
we once the removed regions, we estimate these
regions that we have removed using our algorithm,
and then compared to that of the original data.
So here what we have, we have the original data,
but it's kind of, I mean, the model doesn't
know that there, there was removed. Okay,
I mean, so you could extend this algorithm
to the parametric case, like by parametrizing
this gappy spod model so that it can, not
only, you know, recover the missing data,
but also predict the new source. Yes,
yeah, it has not been seen. Yes, yes,
that that's that's we have been trying, with some
collaborators doing working on that. Yeah, okay,
okay, so to just summarize this part of
my talk, so we have a new algorithm that
leverages both spatial and temporal coherence of
spod for reconstructing these missing data for
especially for statistically stationary flows,
and it outperforms both creaking and gappy pod
and one thing which I've not shown here, but
we have also observed, is that it works well
in the presence of high noise. So here, even
on remove, even on removing, once we remove
this region. So even in the presence of noise, we
can estimate this without the presence of noise,
this might require some fine tuning, but we
can, this can also be done for the presence
of a noisy data. So now moving on to the second
part of my talk. So in in this I will focus on
characterizing the intermittency of these coherent
structures and show how they will correspond to
the different extreme events. So intermittency
is a characteristic of turbulent flows. So here
I'm showing two different examples. One is the
bursting of these streaks. So streaks are this
long meandering structures where they meander,
and finally they burst into form these vertices.
Another example of intermittency is in the case
of super direct to radiation. As you can see here,
this is a super direct to radiation being
emitted in a jet. So if I choose a point
in the far field and look at its pressure
time series signal. So this is what we get,
where you can clearly see this high regions of
high activity. So the commonly used techniques
for characterizing intermittency are are wavelet
transform and short term Fourier transform. So
if you perform wavelet transform on this time
series signal, in addition to the time instances
where we have this high activity, we also get the
information of the frequency, as can be shown by
here, y axis. So these methods, both wavelet
transform and short term Fourier transform,
only characterize intermittency locally, that
is at each spatial location or instant so,
as opposed to this, what we do is we propose
a method that takes into account the entire
spatially coherent flow structures and and tries
to characterize the intermittency of this. For
this, what we do is we will extend spod for for
identifying the frequency time analysis. So,
so in the previous part of my talk, where I
have used inverse spod, in this case, we get
the expansion coefficient for each block, but we
actually require the expansion coefficients for
each snapshot. That is, we require time continuous
expansion coefficients. So in order to do this,
if we would, we would actually require
performing spod with a very high overlap,
but this in many cases, is computationally
intractable. So to circumvent this, what we
do is we take a convolution approach, where we
first project the data onto these spod modes and
then move them one snapshot at a time, and then
perform the convolution over each over each of
this and to obtain the expansion coefficients A so
these are time continuous now. So once we get this
expansion coefficient, we can then reconstruct
the back the data using this expression. So these
expansion coefficients contain. Both the frequency
as well as temporal information of that that of
the corresponding of the corresponding spod modes.
So this will give this will give us the idea,
give us the information of intermittency
corresponding to this coherent structures.
So here, to identify the intermittency. What
we use is, we use the frequency time diagrams
that that we plot by taking the absolute value of
these expansion coefficient and here, I'm showing
the contribution of the leading 10 modes and that
of the leading mode over here. And these, these
regions where we have high intensity regions,
or which is in represented in bright yellows,
represents the time instances where there is
a high similarity between the SPO spod mode of
that corresponding to that frequency and that of
that of the snapshot. And later, I will show that
these actually also correspond to the high energy
events. So, so these are, for example, represents
these, these high instances where there's a
high similarity between spod mode and that of
the snapshot. So these frequency time analysis
give us the temporal information, whereas the
spod spectrum gives us the statistical information
of these go of these spod modes. So if we would
to take the expectation, expected value of the
expansion coefficient of for each frequency, and
we will see that they show a beautiful collapse
to the to that of the eigenvalue spectrum. And
then they are perfect in this case. So this only
shows us two different sides of the same coin. So
this represents the temporal information, and
there is this only shows us the statistical
information. So now to look at the presence of
high energy events, what we do is, for example,
we look at in this region where from 1200 to 1600
and look at the instantaneous energy of the entire
of the entire data, and rank on approximation of
the data. And in both cases, what we observe is we
observe that there is that the energy peaks at the
same time instances that corresponds to this high
energy event. So this corresponds to this bright
yellow spot. So this indicates that, especially
this region indicates that whenever there's
a high similarity between the mode and that
of the snapshot, that that actually corresponds
to a high energy event of this and now finally,
here I would like to show the deconstruction of
the flow field and physical in a physical sense.
So for here, I will choose a different frequency,
the frequency of point five. This I have chosen
specifically because it corresponds
to the Kelvin Helmholtz wave packet.
And here, what I'm showing is the absolute value
of the expansion coefficient. And this is the
this is the magnitude for this. And we know that
this is the time instance that curves that has
the maximum value, global maximum. So I will
choose this and then plot the original field
and compare that with the mode weighted by its
expansion coefficient of here so on doing so,
we can clearly see that at this time instant,
the original flow field orients itself in such
a way that it resembles the kiln Helmholtz wave
packet in that of the near field. And whereas,
obviously, the higher the larger wavelength
structures are not obtained because they present.
They are present in a much lower frequency, and
even once, if we scale them with the expansion
coefficient as well, we can obtain a good match
over here. So this is a qualitative comparison for
a quantitative comparison. Here, what I'm doing
is I'm taking the real part of pressure along
the lip line that is r equal to point five,
and plot that for the that of the spod mode,
for that of the original snapshot, and that of the
mode weighted by this expansion coefficient shown
on the on the right y axis. So here we observe a
perfect phase alignment for this. So overall, what
this shows is there are time so as the turbulent
flow is intermittent in at some time instances, it
orients itself into the form of a wave packet. And
whenever this happens, it it actually corresponds
to the high energy bus over here. And finally,
to to conclude this part of my talk. So here,
we have first shown how this can be used for
identifying the intermittency of the different
cohort structures, and how it can detect the
frequency time analysis. So here, additionally,
there are some other extensions which I've
shown. So. But could not go right due to the
constraint of time. This includes denoising
and another work which was recently done by
my colleague on reduced order modeling, where
they use this expansion coefficient and a coupon
based operator for modeling flows. Now, now
I will move on to the last part of my talk,
where I will focus on the triadic interactions. So
that is, we extend spod to third order statistics,
that is, to optimize the third order statistics
and characterize these triadic interactions.
So the quadratic non linearity arises from the
convective term, convective term in the Navier
stone equations that is given by this expression.
So, so if we take the Fourier transform of the of
the velocity, we get different frequencies. And
if we plug this back into this expression, then
there is a cross interaction between different
frequencies, so f1 interacts with f2 to give
rise to f1 plus f2 and various other different
combinations. So this is what we consider.
This is what we call it as a triad, where two
frequencies are interacting to give rise to the
third one. And this is the corresponding modal
representation of this. So triads still now have
more have mostly been investigated at at a single
spatial location, but not not, but not between
different coherent structures. So what we do is
we focus, we take a more global perspective of
this and use these. Use the BI spectral mode
decomposition to identify these different
triadic interactions. Yeah. So first to first give
this. This is in in signal processing techniques.
What people have done is the point wise by
spectrum. So that is given by this expression,
which is nothing but a expectation of three
different frequencies. And what our method,
that is the BI spectral mode decomposition, does
is it take, it come, it essentially computes an
intake spatial integral of these entire three,
these three, three different frequencies over all
different variables, and how to and on doing.
So we get this BMD, or the mode by spectrum
that is shown here. So to interpret this so we
have on the x axis frequency one, and on the y
axis frequency two, and along diagonals of slope
minus one, the sum of these two frequencies are
constant. So if we look at the top top isolator
triangle, this represents the sum interactions
between f1 and f2 and the bottom right triangle
represents the difference interactions between
f1 and minus f2 and a special case in the case of
turbulent flows is along the lower diagonal, which
where f2 is equal to minus f1 and corresponds, and
corresponds to the mean flow deformation case. So,
so And these, how and these modes by spectrum has
has high intensity, regions which represents the
highest, which represents the highest, radical
interactions with the strongest intensity. So in
BMD, what we do is we essentially, we essentially
compute this bi spectral density matrix shown
here, and know that this circle is nothing but a
hard product here, and because this matrix b is
non Hermitian, what we have to do is we have to
solve a numerical radius problem, as opposed to
the eigenvalue problem, to obtain a one. And once
we obtain the expansion coefficients, we can then
compute the mode by spectrum that is given by
this and that of the DMD modes that corresponds
to the to the different that that shows the that
shows the coherent structures corresponding to
the different triadic interval. Interactions.
And to show the efficacy of our method. Here,
what we do is we perform, we show it on a forced
turbulent on first turbulent jets. And so we
perform first turbulent jets as as it is a first
step towards performing closed loop control of
jet noise, and so. So we have first simulated
an unforced, turbulent jet and then forced at
different frequencies, and we have numbers. And
we have also validated our simulations against the
companion experiments that have been performed at
University of poet a by Peter Jordan's group, and
we observe a good match, both for the unforced as
well as the for the first cases. So first, before
I dive into the BI spectral analysis, I will,
here, I will show an overall energetic analysis,
so for the unforced case. So here different. M
represents the different azimuthal wave numbers.
So for the unforced case, we observe a broadband
like spectrum, whereas for the first case,
we observe peaks at different frequencies. In
particular in the M equal to zero case, we observe
peaks only for the axisymmetric component, whereas
for the higher wave number forcing, we observe
peaks at different wave numbers. In particular,
if we first look at the m plus minus one forcing
more clearly, we observe that we observe peaks
at harmonic wave numbers. At harmonic peaks at
even harmonic frequencies in even azimuthal wave
numbers. That is m zero has 246, and and the odd
azimuthal wave numbers have peaks at order, at odd
harmonic frequencies. And in the coming slides,
I will actually show that this is actually a
resultant of the different hiding interactions
they try, they occur in such a way that they
only give rise to odd harmonic frequencies in
order wave numbers and so on. So now, if we
first perform by spectral mode decomposition
for the unforced and forced jet, what we get are
these two spectra, where, for the unsourced case,
we get a similar to what we had observed
previously, observed a broadband like nature,
with most of the energy at low at low frequencies
and and the energy decays significantly as we go
to higher frequencies. Whereas for the force jet,
we observe a grid like pattern, where with local
maxima at the intersection of these grid lines,
and here is a closed, closed zooming view for this
where we observe that the most dominant triadic
interactions are due to the self interaction of
the forcing frequency with itself, and due to
the destructive interference between the second
harmonic and that of the fundamental frequency. So
this is this triad is actually representative of
a feedback or a backscatter effect. Backscatter
effect where there is energy being going from a
higher frequency to a lower frequency. So this
show, this gives us a framework to identify
the different triadic interactions in forced
or tonal jets. So now, if we have to look at
the plus minus one or plus minus six four
cases, we have to, we have to shift to a
three dimensional representation for this. So for
this, I have different planes where corresponding
to different azimuthal wave numbers. So
we first harmonically force these two,
these two modes, which are represented by
these coherent structures. So on forcing them,
what for the basic interaction is they
interact with each other to give rise to m,
m zero and the second harmonic of two SDF. Over
here, another pathway also exist where these
both can self interact to give rise to m2 and
m minus two and two SDF and and in this case,
what we have, what we observe is both these
mode and this mode are actually symmetric,
or complex symmetric. So what we observe, so
that's why I will only represent them in the in
the positive plane, and positive plane just for
the sake of redundancy. And so this represents
a forward cascade in a wave number as well as in
frequency space. Furthermore, once we obtain, once
we obtain these coherent structures by the result
of the First Order interactions, then a higher
order interactions will occur when this can
interact with this to give rise to higher terms,
as can be shown here. So in all these cases,
what we observe is one and minus one will try
to give two and zero and then higher terms. And
the overall trend observed here is as interactions
results in higher frequencies. They have a much
smaller wavelengths, and these wavelengths and
these coherent structures are concentrated in the
region near to the nozzle lip and and for higher,
higher freak, higher wave numbers, these exhibit
a larger swirl and to finally explain what we had
previously observed. So we can clearly see that
these triadic interactions are the result why we
only observed peaks in even harmonics in the
even azimuthal wave numbers and peak set odd
harmonics in the odd azimuthal wave numbers. So
this, using the BI spectro mode decomposition and
the different kind of forcing, we can clearly
show the presence of triadic interactions that
are that are important in turbulent flows. And
finally, to summarize. Is this part of my talk.
So here we have a new framework for identifying
the triadic interactions due to external forcing
or even any tonal frequency. And our method also
identifies the coherent structures associated
with these triadic interactions. And it can,
it can quantify the non linear interactions
across different frequencies and azimuthal
numbers. And finally, to before conclude,
I would like to acknowledge my advisors,
PhD advisor, postdoctoralness and other
collaborators. And I would also like to I would
also like to thank NSF onr and afsr for their
support in my research. And finally, to conclude,
here we have here, I'm sure here, I've shown three
different extensions of of spod and its various
other approaches, where, in the first case,
have looked at the reconstruction of missing data,
and in second case, the intermittency of coherence
structures. And the third case, a non linear
technique for identifying triadic interactions
with this I would like to thank thank you for
your attention and happy to take questions.
Thank you. Thank you so much for the
wonderful talk. Okay, let's have a
training sessions. If you have questions,
please unmute yourself and ask questions.
So let me start with my I guess
it's a comment. So recently,
we have came up with a gappy autoencoder. So
it's, you know, extension of the gap P pod,
but you extended that to the gap p s pod, but we
have bothering extended to the gap P auto encoder,
okay, the motivation of that is, a lot of
times, you know, when you have the dynamics
which is not easily compressible using the
linear subspace representation. You know,
both pod and spod uses the the linear compression,
right? So for that, with the nonlinear manifold
representations such as neural net through the
autoencoder, shown pretty promising compression.
So we use that, and then in order to apply that
to the recovering the missing data, you know,
develop the gapi alternative. So I, you know,
would like to welcome you to check that out. Yeah,
sure, that sounds really interesting. I mean, the
one thing which I mean in many cases, Gabby spod
can like be problematic, is because, in terms of
like data sets, like convergence of data sets,
for example, we require, we require more more
data for it to work better. Right in if it's a if
it's a very short time series, probably the
results might not be as accurate because spod
is entirely based on the statistically stationary
assumption and requires a large amount of large
time series. Lens for look for its conversion.
So I think probably your auto encoder would
not suffer from such a limitation. And yeah, it
would be great to look at, look at that, yeah,
yeah, that is awesome. Well, of
course, it doesn't solve every,
every problems, because the training of the
auto encoder is a lot more expensive than,
yeah,
all right, well, I can see that
like the application of this gap,
PS, pod is not just the turbulence. It can
be applied to many different applications.
Have you reached out, you know, maybe in
your university, probably for you know,
those application guys were physicists who
probably got a lot of benefits from your Kp,
yeah. If you haven't done that,
please do so. I mean, yeah,
sure. I would like to. I mean, I have, like, I
mean, most of my concentration has been, like,
on turbulent flows and, like, simulating
flows. So, I mean, more focused on this,
but yeah. I mean, yeah, sure. I think it
would be nice to reach out to other ones and,
like, look at Yeah. Like, see how it's
applicable for other cases as well. Yeah.
I'm also would like to open that collaboration
opportunity to the folks at Lawrence Livermore
National Lab, yeah, as well as the people
who just joined, you know, you know,
in this DDPS seminar from everywhere. Yeah, all
right. Any other, any questions from. Audience,
yes, I have just one more question on the end of
the second section. I think in the last slide,
you had shown alias data with the
noise, and then the gap is VOD, sort
of regenerating without the noise.
Is the nice in the Las data? Is that
intentionally forced data? Or is
it something created because of
no, we intentionally included the noise? Yes.
Okay, so that's, yeah, and I mean, the in this
case, we have to probably fine tune the gappy spod
algorithm a bit. The only fine tuning is like,
for example. Let me just go back. What we see is,
for example, this is what you get in a normal case
where there's no noise, whereas in the presence
of noise, you would get like a floor, like this,
for example, it's you get these kind of peaks,
and then you get like a white noise spectrum over,
over some region. So then what you would have
to do is you have to probably cut off the you,
I mean, you can use it a proper threshold to
cut, cut this off at that those frequencies
and to then reconstruct this to avoid,
to avoid any noise in reconstruction.
So that's why, when we get this, we
get the place without noise. Yeah.
Thanks. Any other question, I
Well, if not, let's thank our speaker, Akil, for
the wonderful talk, and thank you so much for
coming here and then gave a wonderful talk.
And it was very awesome. It was very nice.
Yeah, thanks. Thanks for Thanks for introducing,
thanks for inviting me and giving, yeah, giving
me the chance to reach out to many people. Yeah,
awesome, awesome. Okay, so that conclude
today's DDPS seminar. Let me start recording
Yeah, if, if anyone has any
questions and would like.